Way more people reading tweets versus newspapers.
Right.
That'd be stunned.
Like if you could get to seed the exact engagement in a good article in the New
York Times on the front page versus one of Donald Trump's tweets,
you know,
two people that motherfuckers are just waiting for their tweets come out as
Donald Trump to Kanye west.
Yeah.
Those are the two most interested tweets people.
Kanye west could just say grapefruit juice and fuck up all of the media to next
day.
What do you think he meant?
Do you think he made it was hungry or he was thirsty?
Connie,
you just tweeted grapefruit juice.
One of the most,
one of the most interesting tweeters up there.
You wait for a Kanye West tweet.
Well,
he's got a free way of expressing himself.
Like,
here's an unfiltered way of expressing myself and a lot of people,
um,
people have mixed feelings about it makes views.
I know black community is a little stressed out right now.
Well,
because of his Trump thing,
but she know what?
Uh,
I don't know how much of that,
it's just two.
There's two things.
One Obama called MC jackass that could weigh on you.
That stung a little bit.
Yeah.
You know,
and then Obama,
when Obama has gone,
Trump takes office.
Trump is willing to let him talk.
Trump's Trump,
Trump old charm him.
Here's the thing,
Joe,
what that set like when I do white clubs,
black clubs,
whatever,
do all type of clubs.
But the thing is,
um,
you,
you first off,
Kanye West has a voice,
not too many.
As much as black people want to throw the towel in on them.
We don't have too many voices that everybody is waiting to hear whether whatever
comes out,
he has a voice.
I believe that Kanye West is trying to say something.
I just don't know what the fuck he's trying to say because I'm not fluent in
easy,
barely know Swahili.
I can't do [inaudible] easy.
And I think he's trying to say something,
but if there was some type of interpreter,
you know,
this would be a dope ever Chappelle show was right now this is what,
this would be a dope ass kid.
Kanye West says something.
It did.
Dave Chappelle is his conscious interpreter.
That would be hilarious.
He does.
Connie says it didn't,
Dave yells up.
You know what I think,
and this is my only talked to him once the phone,
but what I think from studying them and paying attention,
because we're supposed to eventually do a podcast one day is I think he's uh,
he's thinks different.
He does.
He connects dots different.
And that's one of the reasons why he is so prolific with music.
That's what I'm,
that's the point.
I'm making jokes and that's the point I'm saying about not speaking easy,
but here's some people that think like that.
They don't know how to get it out.
It's like,
just speak.
I have been thinking about this.
I love you.
You're my dad.
You Must Subarea here my dad.
You're like my father.
You know how hard that was for the black community here.
Fuck.
You could sell them a clean all you want,
but what you're saying you'd like my father,
it didn't.
Black people sit back like,
could you please explain that?
So we thought this was funny to me.
They of said,
yeah,
you're like a father figure to me.
Like when I was younger,
up until he was Korea hit me with the horrific,
you know,
father was in him in a shootout,
a drive by if this would fuck me up bro.
He said yeah,
when I was younger,
my parents
separated at a young age.
First off,
you had parents,
you already winning motherfucker.
None of my
dad,
my mother and my father.
You know what I'm saying now only that,
no.
Okay,
okay.
Cut My friends money.
His parents.
But he said my parents separated.
I mean they were married.
That's two winds
you up to before you get to and they separate it in.
Mom moved down the street,
you still got to see your fucking father.
So that was a little troubling.
But the whole thing is,
I'm pretty sure at some point kind of West we'll be able to speak a language
that everybody can understand.
Until then it's only half full of people to speak and understand it.
And also right here.
But here's my problem with all this and I've been thinking about this a lot.
They want to medicate him,
right?
Yeah.
Look how effective he is.
Just stop.
Just stop and think about culturally effective in terms of the music that he
makes it.
People love his,
he's a voice.
Yeah.
He creates clothes.
Okay.
He's married.
His place,
conversation and dialogue too.
He does.
His wife makes hundreds of millions of dollars.
They're insanely wealthy,
insanely successful.
If you want to talk about overall success,
they're together.
They have children's,
they're super wealthy.
He produces incredible art that's loved worldwide and they want to medicate him.
Just stop and think about how effective,
but they want to medicate what they want to medicate him to operate.
At what level does that think about how effective he is and yet they want us to
medication or off off.
When he's off medication,
he said himself,
he's his most creative stop and think about how creative he's been,
how successful is,
how well received.
Yeah.
Happy and all these other elements in his life,
but yet they want him to act the way they want him to act.
Well,
you would just want him to take the head off.
You know what I'm saying?
I've made whatever bro.
You can say whatever the fuck you what the black bean wasn't mad cause he would
have had,
they was mad cause it wasn't a fit for a new era.
If that was a new era they would have been more accepting of it.
Man.
We just don't what the ad side.
It's red and white now.
That's a problem.
Anything with red with white letters.
Yo,
I'm telling you,
it's like when I see,
it's so funny now whenever I see a red head I'm like,
Huh.
Like I'm immediately but after show upstate New York and else's,
why dude came up to me,
I have to show and he didn't have what looked like I'm making America great and
hit.
He had make America great again hat and it looked like he had the original one.
You know how you got to,
you know how you got a Boston fan and you're like,
you only been the same night.
It was a brand of American great before.
Like,
he probably sold the Hashtag [inaudible] did they,
here's the thing,
Joe,
this is my,
if I had the hat on this shit,
and at the end of the show,
he was one of the dudes that was continued to laugh in the most,
you know,
and I went up to him and I,
I was like,
Yo,
I gotta get a picture with you.
And I took the piston,
it was a video.
I was like,
yeah,
motherfucker,
y'all see his head.
And he started laughing and we had a good moment.
It wasn't,
no,
I wasn't angry him.
I'm not going to let
think it's hard to get away from it,
but I think Kanye would,
the hat he likes the idea of how it gets people flustered
contrarian.
They get special was triggered,
right?
Yeah.
Excuse me.
All right.
No,
but I'm saying it's like triggered,
like even,
and I,
when I,
when a guy had the hat on and I was talking to,
I heard an aside,
it was like this,
oh,
he's triggered.
And I wasn't,
I wasn't triggered by that when I was training what I would have been triggered
by just how you make me feel with that hot no period.
Period.
You know,
you can come at me like you could come at me with their head on with some fucked
up energy and I could feel it.
But the energy he gave me was like,
I know this may sound crazy.
We was like,
Yo,
you're funny motherfucker with the hat on.
You're like,
okay.
I didn't give a fuck.
Right.
Cause I couldn't let him,
I couldn't let him make me feel like if that's what his intent was,
he's gonna make me feel uncomfortable.
I couldn't do it.
Smile.
He was trying to make you feel on guard.
I think he really does who he was.
I think that's who he was.
But I think that's what it was.
But I know that motherfucker laughing like a motherfucker.